Speaker 1: Why don't we go next
to, you know, we tried last time and it didn't
work? Let's go to Eric from Cancun, Mexico. Eric,
are you with us this time?
Speaker 4:
David, hello. Yes. It's a great pleasure to talk
to you. I've been trying for months and weeks.
Here's the thing I'm thinking and I'm
my family wants to get a passport to us and I
like to visit the Facebook. I've been seeing
your videos and from of cousins and the young
Turks. And I've seen very deranged individuals,
all surveillance and the police and army. I think
it's the same for tourists and foreigners to go
there with all the wackos and psychopaths around.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, everybody needs to do
their own risk assessment, but statistically
speaking, statistically speaking,
the U.S. is not an unsafe place to be. You know,
there are safer and less safe places in the U.S.,
the big country. In the big cities, you have to
take the normal precautions that you take in any
big city, but you need to make that assessment.
I mean, the U.S. is not an unsafe place to go to
statistically. But that doesn't mean bad things
don't happen. Bad things happen all the time. You
really have to make that call.
Speaker 4: And
yeah, I'm I'm really with the mindset that I like
in the song Father of a Bill of Forever Young
hoping for the best with explained words like what
happened in that Molino parcel and other things.
I mean, the martial artists in, say,
years old. Would they be legal for me
to defend myself? Or would I be
charged with assault if I fight back?
Speaker 1: I think you would be perfectly
within your legal rights to defend yourself,
regardless of your martial arts training.
Speaker 4: And yeah, I mean,
it's like, why don't you grab my guy and cowboy
you that I love jujitsu and karate? Yeah.
And. And it's been a pleasure. And
one great thing. Do you remember when
Republicans were mad that Dr. Seuss?
Speaker 1: Yes. And you know,
he's not even a real doctor,
he's not a medical doctor.
Speaker 4: It's and I think they would be angry
because they made it both about choices for the
relatives, for example. He's left leaning
uncle the Lorax. He's nutty, but logic calls
have stirred the sour kangaroo, and he is more
handsome and more wholesome, cussing the Grinch.
Speaker 1: And you think very nice, very nice.
Eric, I love it. How how is Cancun? Which part
of Cancun do you live in the downtown or where?
Speaker 4: And in the heart of downtown,
it's pretty nice, it's like sound that all year,
but the winter is coming racing.
Speaker 1: It's beautiful. All right,
Eric, thank you so much for the call. We love our
Mexican viewers. If you all right, there is Eric
Eric from Cancun, what a call, folks, what a call.
Maybe my new favorite caller, I have to tell you